in the war in Ukraine we're hearing from
soldiers on the front lines of that
country's counter-offensive against
Russian forces they say they're
liberating occupied territory one
Village at a time officials in Ukraine
say the fighting is extremely Fierce Ian
Lee met with one of the Ukrainian units
returning from Battle
they move into position under the cover
of Darkness night vision gives these
Ukrainian soldiers The Edge against the
Russians
morning brings the command attack this
Soldier Paul signed blacksmith led the
first assault
it took us two days to push nearly three
miles he tells me the Russians were dug
in and heavily fortified but intense
artillery fire forced them to flee
quickness of the Russians Retreat is
scattered everywhere in their trenches
weapons here rations there but War has
taught them a lesson it's like I don't
touch he says anything could be booby
trapped have the Russians been putting
up a stiff resistance when we broke the
line of defense then they have a little
panic and they move fast back
their Commander Anton tells me how his
troops moved through the mine infested
tree lines for cover it'd be slow to be
silent and to be safe
uh low silent and safe yeah
when blacksmith and his Squad reached
their final objective Anton gives the
order to dig in are you glad to be
finally going on the offensive you can't
win uh
the war with with defense only and we're
glad to move forward
the 108 territorial Brigade is now
getting some RNR but training never
stops
Ukrainian soldiers are recalibrating
this bmp2 in fact this vehicle right
here was captured from the Russians
earlier this year
professional soldiers many hadn't held a
gun before the war but now they're
battle-hardened Warriors
do you guys believe that you can win
this war
100 everyone believes will win he tells
me morale is high because we're pushing
forward everyone wants victory
the one thing these soldiers wish they
had more of is tanks if they had them
they tell me this war would be over a
lot quicker Tony
Ian Lee force in Ukraine Ian thank you
very much